there has to be another way  hollow earth is kong's home you're the  most amazing thing you've ever seen  godzilla will come from they have an  ancient rivalry  godzilla had left us in peace now he's  performed into war  goji love jingong  this won't end until one of them submits  they have an ancient rivalry godzilla  will come for him  we need kong the world needs him  kong may be our only home  should save our world  [Music]  godzilla versus kong in theaters and on  hbo max the exact same day waited pg-13  i know gia is only a child she's the  only one he'll communicate with  and we need kong  here we go this won't end until one of  them submits  are you sure the monkey's gonna survive  this it's not a sight worry about  oh my god this is so massive  godzilla versus call in theaters and on  hbo max march 31st rated pg-13  we need kong the world needs him  godzilla will come for him  in theaters and on hbo max the exact  same day hated pg-13  you